je vous dis je vous proposais de faire
un jeu qui s'appelle le chiffon mineurs
le chiffre mineur c'est très simple en
version mineure est ce qu'on peut
apporter
s'il vous plaît les les ustensiles c'est
très triste on va faire un petit chiffon
me connaissez chifoumi je suis fou
exactement donc ça veut dire eh bien
précises aux assurés alors attention il
n'ya pas le puits si le puits ne compte
par cinq ce qu'on faisait le puits avant
mais le plus gagne deux fois quand vous
comptez bien donc c'est passé comme le
fait que le but contre hyper fun si l'on
est ce qu'on peut avoir les trucs les
souplet et morceaux de charbon
merci si vous accueillir celui qui perd
devra faire un truc à chaque fois avec
un morceau de charbon c'est à dire que
le premier on rentrait sur la joue de
l'autre le deuxième fera une moustache
noire sur le visage de l'autre bord est
inquiète pas besoin c'est que du bon je
vais commencer je commence avec marianne
à bakhtiar ariane annonce ainsi chiffon
mineurs chifoumi tu te fous de ma gueule
on refait chifoumi f-16 aux à-coups
couple c'est à toi tu te fais un petit
trait à moi bah oui bah bien sûr que je
suis inquiet n'inquiète inquiète sur la
joue tranquille en la matière va talent
et non pas toi à toi je ne sais pas je
dis bon sur un petit away à coeur
[Applaudissements]
attention c'est parti
le gagnant des signera des lunettes sur
le visage de l'autre important et non le
ciseau couple à pied
[Musique]
attention attention tu peux me les faire
au doigt des glacis c'est un plaisir un
texte au nom c'est bien fait et bien
fait tomassi un style art et ses crises
qu'est-ce qu'on pose maintenant parce
qu'on va faire un peu c'est la finale
pro bowl à la finale je propose je
quitte le faire je penserai la terre et
carnot le perdant là en fait l'auteur à
20 secondes pour se faire plaisir sur le
visage c'est vraiment ces 20 secondes
j'aime ce qui est pur bonheur mais plus
au bonheur attention chez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je te demande juste un badaud tub mayer
lui fait honte à la jeunesse installé
près du coeur s'il te plaît mais oui
après trois points noirs allaient à la
scie
québec voilà je suis je suis dans muller
on est happé les gars moi je resterai
une petite serviette à est afin qu'ils
soient quand même
bah ouais non mais t'es tu étais bien
alors